[Music]
hey everyone
wow didn't do anything already got
applause it's a pretty good start I see
a lot of familiar faces but the stage is
getting bigger every year
so hey my name is Sasha puta product on
the product team for Android TV I'm
Benjamin Baxter devrel for Android TV
and thanks for joining the Android TV
session at Google i/o the session is
called what's new but we're also talking
a little bit what has happened in the
last year so thanks for joining and yeah
let's get going so last time most of us
talked was last year at Google i/o and
the Android TV acro system since then
has grown significantly and we are
obviously really happy about that so we
have now more than a hundred partners
working with us on Android TV devices
and as you can see we are doubling that
so far every year and as you can see the
growth comes from a number of devices
and device categories we have maybe
heard at CES earlier this year a bunch
of new partners in very different Smart
TV price categories launching Android TV
devices so we are in the very lucky
position that we can't even list all
partners on one slide anymore so if
you're here if you're working with us on
Android TV devices and your logo is not
here sorry we're running out of space
but also in the setup box space and
specifically when it comes to pay TV
operators we see significant growth and
we are very happy about that so we
already have a thing around 30 partners
worldwide so pay TV operators cable
satellite IPTV shipping boxes with
Android TV and we have more than 50
additional ones coming so we are really
happy and we see good growth there but
it's not only about hardware it's also
about software and that's why I'm I'm
really happy that the TV app ecosystem
is growing significantly as well I think
this is the fifth time I said
significantly so I will stop doing that
but all of you are contributing to apps
having developers here at i/o
over the last few years actually pick up
Android TV and build cool media
experiences games or completely new
stuff we didn't think about it's really
awesome when we started to play the TV
Play Store I think in 2014 we had 25
apps or so now we are approaching 4,000
anything because here there are a lot of
app developers here we wanted to mention
because it's a little bit under the
radar we have also launched DCB on
android TV a lot of you if you're
developing for mobile you know direct
carrier billing already in mobile so if
someone buys an app if someone doesn't
in-app purchase or bicycling your car in
a game you can charge it to your mobile
bill in a lot of cases if you don't have
a credit card or you don't want to use
the credit card and the same concept has
launched also since last Google i/o on
Android TV and we're working with more
and more partners pay TV operator
partners that you can shot do charges
from the Play Store or the Play
ecosystem in general to your cable or
satellite or TV subscription bill but
then also one of the things we have
started putting more emphasis on is the
Google assistance you heard us briefly
talking last year at Google i/o about
this and since then the ecosystem and
the services that the Google assists Inc
brings to Android TV have not only to
Android TV but to devices in general has
grown so we see a lot of use of the
assistant on TV we think it's a great
additional tool to make use
consumption of media services and apps a
lot easier on TV by just interacting
with voice right discovering content by
simply talking to your TV having a very
natural interface not having to remember
what was that search phrase again just
natural and it's easy and it works but
it's not only about finding content it's
also about looking up answers to
questions you might be interested in it
might be with that actor is or it's also
control of other devices in your house
the assistant on Android TV gives you
all of that and so because we think it
is so important we are we are this year
putting a lot of priority on getting the
assistant into more countries we want to
make sure we do it right so we don't
want to rush anything but since we have
launched in the u.s. in late 2017 we are
ringing this year as you can see a lot
more countries into the assistant
ecosystem on Android TV but even if you
are in a country or a language that is
not yet assistant and able and you have
to wait a little bit we refresh our
voice search experience even in those in
those countries so I mentioned earlier
that we're really happy about all the
apps and more and more apps in the Play
Store and we last year here Google I'll
give you a little bit of a sneak peek of
the new Android TV home experience and
the system UI and how apps can integrate
with that back then it was a it was a
sneak peek
it was a preview it has launched with
Android Oreo and we are now have a lot
of partners starting to roll this out to
Android TV devices so we thought it's a
good opportunity to go into more detail
how your apps can actually take
advantage of this content first
experience that we are trying to achieve
with Android TV and then is going to
talk a little bit about what it actually
means content to have a content first
app hey thanks Sasha so we really wanted
to redefine this experience once wanted
to be very content
first content-driven if you're familiar
with the previous screen we have one row
for recommendations a double row for
apps double row for games we've changed
as you can clearly see so apps are still
important
we've have one row for apps it's just
your favorite apps your users can
customize and add your app to this row
it's up to the users discretion that
recommendation row from Android and
below we've broken it up into several
different responsibilities so we have a
play next row where you can add content
and we'll talk more about this later but
you can add content to be picked back
and engage with the user later the next
thing we did was we broke out and each
app can have their own channel they can
have their own surface on the home
screen we're trying to really push this
content first design and every app can
can contribute to it as Sascha mentioned
earlier with the assistant the assistant
is also on the home screen it's not
specific to Android o or Android P it
actually supported from Android M and
above so this is here to enhance search
and keep pushing that content first
design okay I keep saying content first
it's like my favorite phrase all of a
sudden but let's look at some really
good examples before we dive into the
technical details about what builds a
content first design so here we have
Google Play Movies and this is from the
home screen and you can see everything
about their details it's as if the the
movie details screen is right there on
the home screen to help build and engage
in experience this is great for users
they don't have to go into the app and
hop back out they can make decisions
right there from the home screen if we
take it a step further we have video
previews so if you have a movie a
trailer makes a great video preview if
you're an audio app ten-second clip is a
great audio preview we found that having
previews is very engaging for users and
drives engagement into your app I said
earlier about the play next row this is
a great place free to add content to
bring users back in if you're watching a
really long movie you add a little bit
extra metadata will make a beautiful
progress indicator to add more context
and the users are able to hop
back into the app and I said channels
you're not just limited to one little
row on the home screen you can have as
many channels as you want if we look
here you know we have channels like
featured top free these are great
channels that you know we're going to be
fresh you know these have indications of
being updated daily even hourly okay so
now we have a nice context about what's
on the home screen
what's dive into how you guys can build
this experience so what is a channel a
channel is just a logo and a name that's
all it is it's a container for programs
this is gonna be where you theme your
content and and customize everything
deeper in the programs to build a
channel we have a support library it
just uses the Builder pattern super easy
super convenient for you everything on
the home screen should be clickable so
if you click on a logo it should open
back into your app so just set the app
link URI and this will let you open up
your app from the home screen the next
thing that's important is the internal
provider ID this is an ID for your app
to tell the home screen hey keep track
of this I know what this ideas and when
I go to query my channel later I can
synchronize my channel with what the
home screen knows about my app and
that's it it uses a content provider and
we have convenient methods for those of
you that know the know the joys of
content providers you know that there
can be boilerplate code we've abstracted
all that into the support library and we
make it really easy for you to build a
build a content provider API those also
from the earth content providers know
that you are eyes are kind of tedious
and cumbersome to manage the support
library manages all of that for you it's
just a simple insert statement and you
get back a channel ID like I said
earlier with the internal provider ID
you can use the channel ID and the
internal provider ID to make sure when
you synchronize and update your channels
later you'll have all the keys you need
okay channels like I said they're just a
shell of a row the programs are what
really matter so let's look an example
of a program in this program we have a
bunch of stuff happening we have a
thumbnail image we have a title a
description and anything else you know
about this program can be added to the
home screen the more metadata you add
the richer the experience the better the
user engagement so anything that's in
your details page it's perfectly natural
to put on a home screen again Builder
pattern this time you want to set the
channel ID on your program so the home
screen knows where to put it on the home
screen and if your program has more than
one channel it can be in make sure to
add a unique identifier the home screen
will look at this identifier and say hey
we already know about this program in
this channel and it's also in this
channel we can have deduping logic so
that the user doesn't see duplicates and
adds a cleaner smoother experience you
also want to set the type in this
example we set to type the movie but the
type will drive the metadata that's
shown on the home screen and I showed
you with Red Bull earlier video previews
it's as simple as just adding the URI so
you just say hey my video preview is at
HTTP dub dub dub dub my video comm and
the home screen will play the video for
you it uses exoplayer under the covers
so all of this supported video formats
from exoplayer are supportive for you
out of the box if you have DRM or you
have a bit more complex use case we do
support a solution where you can draw
your video on a surface come see us and
office hours tomorrow and we can go in
more depth about that this looks very
similar to channels you know you convert
them to content values and then from
your content values you'll need the URI
the URI is dynamic since you're trying
to insert a program into a specific
channel so use the the support library
after you insert you'll get back a
program ID now your programs in the
channel and you have a program ID and
you have a channel ID you have all the
tools you need for synchronizing
updating and deleting later when you
update your content okay I told you how
to make the channel you know just use
the the Builder pattern add it to the
content provider but when do you make it
win is very important we put a lot of
time trying to figure out how to get you
started and so we ended up with a new
intent
so there's initialized programs that
that will get triggered and this can
happen before your app starts which
isn't a bad idea you know your app just
gets downloaded onto a TV or it gets
updated and all of a sudden you have
content on the home screen great entry
way for users to come into your app just
listen for this initialize programs and
just set up your channels and start your
process okay the last thing we talked
about was the Google assistant I think
the Google assistant is a pretty
fantastic experience it pushes that
content first approach even further
things you can do to integrate the
Google assistant is to implement search
I support deep links and handle playback
controls so let's look further when you
perform a search with the Google
assistant the Google assistant keeps
this content first design search my
favorite movie Big Buck Bunny hope it's
your favorite too and you'll see a bunch
of information the thumbnail the
description the title and if your app
matches you know if it matches on the
title duration year at the minimum with
the metadata returned it will show up in
the list of apps that's available on how
do you match this what happens under the
covers we use more content providers
this time your app is providing data to
the Google assistant the Google
assistant would just pass a URI for you
to perform your search on in this
content provider you can do whatever you
want local database calls Network calls
whatever you need to do to perform your
search you can do it this URI contains
the raw search string from the Google
assistant but it will be sanitized so if
you say something like play Big Buck
Bunny it's going to send you Big Buck
Bunny and realize that play is a command
so just be cognizant that the URI you
get is gonna be the key for what you
should search for okay controlling
playback if you guys are familiar with
media session you don't have to do
anything your app already supports it
but we'll just take a closer look if you
want to if you want to support the the
Google assistant and do different
commands while watching shows for
example hey Google pause the movie in
your app you just implement media
session supply a callback with this
function on pause or on play and the
Google assistant will trigger that
through media session on pause on play
yeah you can just hit the pause play
button on the remote maybe not the most
useful feature but it's there and it's
really it's actually a really cool
experience my favorite one is on seek to
you say hey Google fast-forward five
minutes and the Google assistant
actually does the math and says hey your
media session has a state I know the
current position in that state you said
fast-forward five minutes that's 300
seconds so I'm going to send the new
position to your app if you're familiar
with media session you know that there's
on rewind and on fast-forward you should
still implement those methods but the
Google assistant ignores those since it
already does the math to figure out
where to send the user to this next one
is more useful for audio apps more so
than video apps but if you say hey
Google play the next song or okay Google
go back and play the previous song all
you have to do is just implement on skip
the next and on skip the previous so to
recap what are some of the best
practices on the home screen you should
listen for initialize programs this is
the gateway for creating your programs
and building that experience on the home
screen when it comes to metadata you
cannot have enough the more metadata you
add the richer the experience the better
engagement from users keep it on that
theme of engagement ad previews it's
going to really drive engagement and
build a nice experience for users
keeping content fresh if you have stale
content you might lose trust with users
you know if you have a channel on the
home screen and you haven't updated in
the year you know once the user watches
all those programs they don't have too
much of a reason to go back in so you
want to keep that content fresh and that
that depends on your app if you're an
app like YouTube or haystack and you
have user curated content maybe update
every couple hours if you're an app like
Google Play Movies where the contents
already controlled maybe update once a
day or twice twice a week or so the goal
is to keep the users fresh keep the
content fresh so users have something to
engage with every day and when it comes
to the assistant the media session is
your friend anything you want to do with
Google assistant media session is the
key the good news is all of this stuff
you can do today it's live on Android oh
and and I'm gonna turn it back over to
Sasha to talk about things you guys can
do in the future thank you very much
thanks man it's interesting to see also
the different reactions in the audience
like some people taking notes and taking
photos and discussing the the code
slides and other people like dude just
launched some devices so we'll talk a
little bit more about what's new you
heard this morning already from Dave
Burke and some others what what's the
new stuff in Android pee and of course
Android TV will also get some new
additions in Android pee so I will only
highlight a few areas we're investing in
one is definitely performance we have
done a lot of work in Android pee to
actually make Android TV perform better
faster even on entry-level hardware so
even on some of the very affordable
smart TVs you might have seen or set up
boxes we want to make sure everything is
iffy it's fast and we have invested a
lot in that an Android P and as
developers some things to take a look at
is think about your app and your app
behavior is there maybe something like
some animation some feature you might
want to disable or tweak on low memory
devices we see that's one of the most
common problems for some apps on
entry-level hardware so take a look at
the is low RAM device and human your app
behavior to that play around a little
bit with with it maybe it's some tweaks
to animations or maybe on certain device
devices disabled disabled animations or
take a look at certain features also use
the memory profiler to really check your
app profile it see where it might run
into some bottlenecks because we see
that still being some of the most common
behaviors that an app suddenly has a
drop in fps and also then use android
vitals to monitor the performance of
your application but again you see you
should see android pee on energy v
devices perform much faster and much
better and we will see more devices
because of the reduce hardware envelope
but we also obviously wanted to update
some things for users and make make it
even easier to get to a fully setup
Android TV experience I mean let's let's
be honest not everyone enjoys
necessarily setting up a new device and
we wanted to make it the whole
experience of from unboxing the device
to have everything ready Li set up be a
lot easier faster and you don't have to
deal a lot with it so in Android P the
whole setup process is a lot more
streamlined I think we reduced the
overall time it takes you to go through
there by almost a third and we also have
some additional clue queues in there
where the phone integration is better if
you have an Android phone you will get a
set up notifications so you can transfer
account details for example your Google
account you can easily transfer that to
the TV also we have we have improved the
browser sign-in for non Android devices
so iOS devices or maybe a laptop we
improved that a lot it's it's a lot
faster it's a lot easier and so we
should get you through setup a lot
easier but that's only setting up the
device with your account and making sure
all the all the settings work what you
also want on a Smart TV or an OTT box
you also want all your apps right you
want all the content so as part of the
setup process we also have what we
generally of play auto installs and we
already recommend you apps that you have
installed on other Android TV devices on
past Android TV devices or maybe on your
phone if a corresponding TV app exists
so we automatically suggest that to you
as part of the set up flow and you can
select there yes I want all these apps
or maybe say oh I want only a few of
them just a few clicks checkboxes you
say go and everything is being
downloaded and installed automatically
no more manual search in the Play Store
after you have set up a new device
but downloading and installing an app is
only one piece that we wanted to
optimize what's also not a great
experience is going into an app and then
discovering that you have to sign in
with the username and password and
having to awkwardly enter that with your
remote control and so that's why we're
introducing also autofill with Google on
Android TV so if you have ever entered
your credentials on one of these apps on
another Android device we automatically
suggesting that those to you you just
say yes and all the login credentials
are being added you're logging in
automatically without entering and
usernames or passwords so that's set up
but also one of the things one of the
area where we saw a lot of users spend a
lot of time and searching for stuff and
obviously not really enjoying it is
settings right sometimes you need to
tweak stuff or you have skipped a
certain set up step when setting up your
new device or you want to change your
audio settings or add a different
account or something like this and we
have revamped settings on Android TV to
be a lot more streamlined a lot less
cluttered and we will automatically
suggest to you settings we think you are
looking for and for example when you
skipped account login we as you see in
the animation here will already
highlight that or when we saw you tweak
around with some apps and something
wasn't right and you go into settings we
will maybe highlight the app setting for
you we want to make it as easy to
quickly get in get the stuff tweaked you
need and get out again
so there was a lot about Android pee it
you can download the Android PE preview
SDK and can play around with the with
the mu also with the TV emulator and try
it out there are some other neat things
in there for example external camera
support so you could start writing
camera apps for TV if you want to so you
can can start playing around with it
we're also going to release a lot more
documentation around the performance
aspects of TV apps in the near future
but we wanted to talk about two more
things I mean we talked a lot about
software so far but we also thought
about what a cool hardware experience
what are cool devices that could expand
the experience in the living room and
one of the questions we asked ourselves
is how would a really cool living room
experience where the device being the
center the hub of the living room with
assistant integrated very easy to use
controlling all my other devices and
bring me the best Android TV experience
onto my TV screen how would something
like that look like and the outcome of
that asking the answer to that was
something like this
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Google turn on the TV okay cool
play the Clemson football game on ESPN
okay what's it called again
curiosity opportunity hey Google what's
the new Star Trek show here is some
information about Star Trek discovery
discovery hey Google show me potato
battery videos on YouTube kids
all right here's potato battery videos
on YouTube kids college football
overtime according to Wikipedia it is
commonly ten minutes long this is good
this is really good hey Google buy more
kettle corn here's what I found on
Google Express
I meant the show I know hold up hey
Google dim the lights turn off the TV
and play some music on Pandora
[Music]
[Applause]
so as you might have seen already
starting yesterday in some media outlets
we announced without together with our
partner JBL the JBL link bar powered by
Android TV it's an awesome sound bar it
has Google assistant integrated and
because we put far-field microphones
into the device you don't even need to
pick up the remote control you just sit
on the sofa start talking to the device
and can control the whole experience it
has really awesome sound
there will be an optional subwoofer that
you can order with it as well and but
what I think a really cool feature is
other three HDMI ends and you might
think well why is that so cool you
really can't control your whole home
entertainment experience with this
because a lot of you might have actually
well you might have a Playstation or an
Xbox right or you might still have that
blu-ray player or whatever other or
maybe that cable set-top box you still
really like so you can connect all these
devices to the JBL link bar and then use
the assistant to control for example you
want to switch to the PlayStation and it
just magically happens and also if let's
say you're playing a game on the
PlayStation and then you have a question
for the assistant you just ask the
assistant and the assistant can answer
can show you the answer cards over your
current HDMI input so it's not just the
pass-through HDMI these are active
inputs and it really shows you the power
of the assistant and Android TV as a
living room platform and the other cool
thing here is that it works that we that
we are working to get this the into a
speaker only mode as well because
sometimes you don't need the TV screen
right you don't to listen to audio to
listen to music to maybe just ask
something really turning this down into
a very low-key smart speaker it's also
cool so this device can do all of those
things and maybe sometimes you just want
to send some use
by a Bluetooth or a cast audio - the
device works as well it's your one-stop
shop for the living room you can control
everything it's super easy it will also
come with a remote control but if you
prefer to just use it with voice well it
is really easy you should check it out
we have it in our Android TV sandbox
here in sandbox C and ask some of the
folks from the team to give you a demo
it's really cool it sounds good and it
will launch in fall 2018
so I said two more things right so one
other thing we talked a lot about
Android pee earlier and like as
developer you want to follow all the
things Ben just told you and you might
ask yeah you told me I can download the
Android pee SDK preview SDK and work
with the emulator but I really would
like to have actual hardware for this so
I don't know who of you was around was
at Google i/o 2014 at Moscone Center in
lots of hands okay
some of you were already in Moscone and
2014 and they might remember we launched
a device back then to introduce Android
TV was called the ADT one so we thought
well you can applaud if you want but we
thought it's time for another developer
device so we are introducing ADT to
[Applause]
so you might want to write down that
signup form link because you're the
first people to actually see this and be
able to sign up for this
all the smartphones we is actually a
pretty good test for google lens the
actual anyway if they go to the sandbox
later and check out the soundbar and you
just badge in you also get an email to
slink as well yep good point so this is
a neat little hdmi dongle it will come
with a btle enabled sorry a voice
enabled remote control so you can try
out all the assist in the integration
tips that Ben just talked about it will
run an Android P Developer Preview
release
we will send updates to the device by
the way we are also sending updates to
the soundbar Google or the Android TV
team cents will sent the system updates
and you Android versions right through
the device and so you can use this
device to try out all the cool things
it's a limited edition device so you
know about it first sign up we will
actually start to send this out later
this summer and little device we are
actually really excited about it and
sign up for it and build cool apps
that's kind of it already I said two
more things it was two more things we
have if you're working on apps we have
some more interesting events that you
might be interesting to much interested
in then I don't know if you want to
mention come visit us in office hours we
have back-to-back app reviews and office
hours we're going to be down the road a
little bit where the office hours tent
is if you have questions come bring them
if you're bored and you still want to do
TV stuff we have two new code labs in
the code lab section one focuses on just
the play next row and the other one
focuses on an overview of the entire
home screen we look forward to seeing
you and bring your questions there yep
and talking about questions
well obviously we want feedback from you
but also if you have if you have
questions
you see those microphones we're not
using them because of timing we will get
shuffled out here very soon but Ben and
I will be over right after this talk in
the Android TV sandbox come over talk to
us ask us questions and I will most
likely Paul talk a point to Ben to
answer those questions thank you very
much bill cool TV apps and I hope we'll
see you next year thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you